GILBERT STRANG: OK.
We're still solving systems
of differential equations
with a matrix A in them.
And now I want to
create the exponential.
It's just natural to produce
e to the A, or e to the A t.
The exponential of a matrix.
So if we have one
equation, small a,
then we know the solution
is an e to the A t,
times the starting value.
Now we have n equations with
a matrix A and a vector y.
And the solution should be,
at time t, e to the A t,
times the starting value.
It should be a perfect
match with this one, where
this had a number
in the exponent
and this has a matrix
in the exponent.
OK.
No problem.
We just use the series
for e to the A t.
We plug in a matrix
instead of a number.
So the identity, plus A
t, plus 1/2 A t squared,
plus 1/6 of A t cubed, forever.
It's the same.
It's the exponential series.
The most important series
in mathematics, I think.
And it gives us an answer.
And that answer is a matrix.
Everything here, every
term, is a matrix.
OK.
Now, is that the right answer?
We check that by putting it
into the differential equation.
So I want to put that
solution into the equation.
So I need to take
the derivative.
The derivative of
this is the derivative
of-- that's a constant.
The derivative of that is A.
The derivative of this is 1/2.
I have an A squared,
and I have a t squared.
The derivative of t squared
is 2t, so that'll just be a t.
The 2 and the 2 cancel.
OK.
Now I have A cubed here.
t cubed?
The derivative of t cubed is 3t
squared, so I have a t squared.
And the 3 cancels
the 3 and the 6,
and leaves 1 over 2
factorial, and so on.
And I look at that.
And I say it's very
much like the one above.
Look.
This series is just
A times this one.
Multiply the top one by A.
A times I is A. A times A t
is A squared t.
Term by term, it
just has a factor A.
So it's A e to the A
t, is the derivative
of my matrix exponential.
It brings down an A.
Just what we want.
So then if I add
a y of 0 in here,
that's just a constant vector.
I'll have a y of 0.
I'll have a y of 0 here.
When I put this into the
differential equation,
it works.
It works.
Now, is it better than what
we had before, which was using
eigenvalues and eigenvectors?
It's better in one way.
This exponential, this
series, is totally fine
whether we have n independent
eigenvectors or not.
We could have
repeated eigenvalues.
I'll do an example.
So for with repeated eigenvalues
and missing eigenvectors,
e to the A t is still
the correct answer.
Still the correct answer.
But if we want to use
eigenvalues and eigenvectors
to compute e to
the A t, because we
don't want to add up an
infinite series very often,
then we would want n
independent eigenvectors.
So what am I saying?
I'm saying that this e
to the A t-- All right,
suppose we have n
independent eigenvectors.
And we know that that
means, in that case,
a is V times lambda
times V inverse.
And we can write V
inverse because the matrix
V has the eigenvectors.
This is the eigenvector matrix.
If I have n independent
eigenvectors,
that matrix is invertible.
I have that nice formula.
And now I can see
what is-- e to the A
t is always identity plus A.
I'm now going to use
the diagonalization,
the eigenvectors, and
the eigenvalues for A.
So I'm doing the
good case now, when
there are a full set of
independent eigenvectors.
Then the A t is V
lambda V inverse t.
That's right, that's I, plus
A t, plus 1/2 A t squared.
Right?
So I need A squared.
So everybody remembers
what A squared is.
A squared is V lambda V inverse,
times V lambda V inverse.
And those cancel out to give
V lambda squared V inverse,
times t squared, and so on.
You remember this A squared,
so I'll take that away.
And look at what I've got.
Look what I've got it.
Yes.
Factor V out of the
start, and factor
V inverse out of the end.
And in here I have V times V
inverse is I, so that's fine.
V times V inverse,
I have a lambda t.
V and a V inverse, so I
have a 1/2 half lambda
squared t squared.
And so on, times V inverse.
This is all just
what we hope for.
We expect that a V goes out
at the far left at the front.
This V inverse comes
out at the far right.
And what do you
see in the middle?
You see-- so this is now my
formula for e to the A t, is V.
And what do I have there?
I have the exponential
series for lambda t.
So it's e to the
lambda t V inverse.
And what is e to the lambda t?
Let's just understand
the matrix exponential.
When the matrix is diagonal,
the best possible matrix,
this will be V. What
does my matrix look like?
V inverse.
If I'm looking at
this, looking at this.
Lambda is diagonal.
All these matrices are
diagonal with lambdas.
So that'll be e to the lambda
1t down to e to the lambda nt.
I'm not doing anything
brilliant here.
I'm just using the
standard diagonalization
to produce our exponential
from the eigenvector matrix
and from the eigenvalues.
So I'm just taking
the exponentials
of the n different eigenvalues.
So e to the A t.
This would lead to e to the A
t y at 0, would be-- y of 0 is
some combination.
And then there's an e to the
lambda 1t coming from here.
And there's an x eigenvector x1,
plus C2 e to the lambda 2t x2,
so on.
That's the solution
that we had last time.
That's the solution that using
eigenvalues and eigenvectors.
Now.
Can Can I get
something new here?
Something new will be,
suppose there are not
a full set of n
independent eigenvectors.
e to the A t is still OK.
But this formula is no good.
That formula depends
on V and V inverse.
And suppose we have an example.
So all that is very nice.
That's what we expect.
But we could have a
matrix like this one.
A equals-- well,
here's an extreme case.
What are the eigenvalues
of that matrix?
It's a diagonal matrix.
The eigenvalues are 0 and 0.
The eigenvalue of 0 is repeated.
It's a double eigenvalue.
And we hope for
two eigenvectors,
but we don't find them.
That has only one
line of eigenvectors.
It only has an x1
equals 1, 0, I think.
If I multiply that A, times
that x1, gives me 0 times x1.
That's an eigenvector.
Well, because the
eigenvalue is 0,
I'm looking for the null space.
There is in the null
space, but the null space
is only one-dimensional.
Only one eigenvector.
Missing an eigenvector.
Still, still, I can
do e to the A t.
That's still completely correct.
That series will work.
So to do this series I
need to know a squared.
So I'm actually going
to use the series,
but you'll see that
it cuts off very fast.
a squared, if you work
that out, it's all 0's.
So our e to the A t is just
I, plus A t, plus STOP.
A squared is all 0's.
A cubed is all 0's.
So the matrix e to the A
t is identity, a times t.
a is this, times t is
going to put a t there.
There you go.
That's a case of the
matrix exponential,
which would lead us to the
solution of the equations.
Of course, it's a pretty
simple exponential.
But it comes from
pretty simple equations.
The equations dy dt, that
system of two equations,
with that matrix in it.
Our system of equations
is just dy1 dt,
I have a 1 there so
it would be a y2.
And dy2 dt is 0
on the second row.
Well, that's pretty
easy to solve.
In fact, this tells you how
to solve-- you could naturally
ask the question, how do we
solve differential equations
when the matrix doesn't
have n eigenvectors?
Here's an example.
This matrix has only
one eigenvector.
But the equation that we just
solved by, you could say,
back substitution.
This gives Y2 equal constant.
And then that equation, dy1 dt
equal that constant, gives me
y1 equals t times constant.
That's what I'm seeing.
Oh.
Yeah.
Are you surprised to
see a t show up here?
Normally I don't see a t
in matrix exponentials.
But in this repeated
case, that's
the t that we're
always seeing when
we have repeated solutions.
Everybody remembers that when
we have second-order equations,
and we have the two
exponents are the same.
So we only get one solution
of that, e to the st.
And we have to look
for another one.
And that other one is?
te to the st. It's
that same t there.
OK.
There is an example
of how a matrix
with a missing eigenvector,
the exponential pops a t in.
The exponential pops a t in.
And if I had two
missing eigenvectors,
then in the exponential.
Shall I just show you an example
with two missing eigenvectors?
Let a be-- well, here it
would be 0, 0, 0, 0, 0,
triple 0, with, let's say.
There's a matrix with
three 0 eigenvalues,
but only one eigenvector.
So it's missing
two eigenvectors.
And I would, in the
end, in e to the A t
here, I would see
probably 1, 1, 1, t, t,
and probably I'll see
a 1/2 t squared there.
A little bit like that.
But one step worse.
Because the triple
eigenvalue, well, that's
not going to happen
very often in reality.
But we see what it produces.
It produces a t squared
as well as the t's.
OK.
So, the x matrix
exponential gives
a beautiful, concise, short
formula for the solution.
And it gives a formula
that's correct,
even in the case of
missing eigenvectors.
Thank you.